[Hank:] Good Morning John.
I spent last weekend in Glacier National Park
A place that is dripping with scenic beauty and absolutely no cell phone signals
That might have something to do with all the extremely sharp cliffs and jutting rock formations
and a desire not to like build cell phone towers on some of the most scenic mountains in the world
There is a road. It was completed in the 1930s that bisects Glacier National Park
called the Going to the Sun Road
Its a little bit terrifying
as for a great deal of the time, especially on the way up,
you're basically driving 3 feet away from a precipitous drop.
If you are in the car and not driving there's this weird sensation that you need to lean away
from the cliff.
Even though obviously that's not gonna
help anything if the car goes over
but you shouldn't lean away from the cliff. You should lean toward the cliff because
that's where the best view is. It's a
little strange that this road was even built
It continues to be an engineering
marvel because of avalanches and
freeze-thaw cycles the road needs
constant repair and the road doesn't
actually go anywhere except to the top:
Logan Pass which during the winter is
regularly covered in more than 80 feet
of snow. The Going to the Sun Road closes in September and doesn't open again until July
It almost seems like a
uniquely American thing.  There's this
beautiful place but people can't get to
it unless they're ridiculously dedicated.
So let's spend millions of dollars
building a miracle of a road, in fact
let's give it a miraculous sounding name.
We have to democratize access to this
grandeur in this beauty and these cute
ground squirrels and these majestic
mountain goats. But you cannot snapchat
them while you're up there because your cell
phone doesn't work you have to wait
until you get back to your hotel room
and then when you get there you'll check
the news and find out that once again
Donald Trump has said something
disgusting and inexcusable that somehow
hasn't disqualified him from seeking the
presidency of this beautiful place.
Listen, I'm not much of a nationalist.
Part of what I like about Glacier
National Park is that the ecosystem it
contains stretches between international
borders and into Canada's Waterton Lakes
National Park indeed a commitment to
being a proactive part of the global
systems on which we rely economically
socially and ecologically is part of
what I
love about being an American and I
really do love this country though that
gets harder during election years which
always highlight what I dislike about
being an American. We work so hard to
demonize each other that everyone comes
out looking like demons. And yes, that
looks a lot worse this time around than
it did last time, and yes, I do feel
particularly discouraged but it's easy
to forget what this country has done:
what we have built, what it costs us, and
how easy it is to be proud of it. All you
have to do is not look at twitter for a
few hours and instead look at what we've
built
Yes, we have problems, and yes, it makes
sense that we spend a lot of time
discussing them because after all they
are the problems but god damn it if I
don't love this country even in the face
of the popularity of a despicable man
God damn it if I'm not proud to be an American.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday
[Hank:] This isn't a scary part.
[Katherine, offscreen:] Okay
[Hank:] Wide road,
[Man, offscreen:] Oh!
[Katherine:] Yeah
[Hank:] Wide road
[Man:] I just pooped my pants
[Katherine:] Put them back!
[Hank:] Not a lot of cars,
[Katherine:] Oh my God, I'm gonna murder you
[Hank, offscreen:] They did say that we should get
off the roads by a certain time
[Katherine:] That's hail.
[Hank:] Yeah, it hailed a little bit.
[Katherine:] That's some hail
[Hank:] Oh, aye, hey there
[Katherine:] Oh, you missed it.
[Hank:] Oh, I missed it pooping
[Hank:] Wow, you don't mind so much
Oh, gosh you're cute
Oh, gosh, you're a healthy looking chipmunk
[Man:] Face, he's making the face, yeah
[Hank:] Oh, yep
Oh, there's a baby bison pooping
[Katherine:] Everybody poops, guys
[Hank:] Good job.